take us back to those days you're a
young guy remembered how young you were
when you came on the show I was 20 23
you were 23 years old you came on the
show and immediately I felt like this
everybody everybody said this is a
really funny guy such a sweet guy did
you did you feel comfortable there right
away I was very excited I remember
thinking I was very confident member
yeah Mike the first night I met you and
Odin Kirk and Smigel I was telling you
guys how I'm gonna be a huge star and
you were like oh okay yeah I was I was a
little aggressive and a little nuts and
stupid and I don't know I kept telling
Laura no I'm the next Eddie Murphy he's
like all right whatever this confidence
I had it it all went away but it I got a
little smarter but I I remember hanging
out there and I remember my office was
with it was me and rock shared an office
even Chris rakia and then Farley and I
stayed we were all like we all go out to
dinner that was a member walling
Joseph's how much fun happened yeah we
go out and net what my favorite thing
the writing staff we would take a host
out to dinner and every weekend we took
Michael Keaton out and we were all so
excited to hang with Michael Keaton it
was like 25 of us showed up and we had
this giant meal and the check comes and
Keaton grabs the check and everyone's oh
no no no no Saturday night I will pay
for videos no no no let me get this and
we were like no no come on man
and he goes
now Cohen
you remember Farley's order when we
would go out yeah yeah properly loved to
eat he loved he but you would agree that
I've never seen I've never seen since I
mean by any human being yeah he
literally it was the funniest because
the waiter would make the rounds of the
you know like four or five of us and
he'd give your order and you'd feel
Farley's energy like alright come on let
me go already
and then he would order his food and
then he would say you know you got the
t-bone steak and okay and do you have a
name like six things you were like wow
he's getting six things and then he
would say okay I'll take two of those
what was the hold on I need bring out
two steaks for him and two salads and
two sides of every side he ordered and
it was like the quietest farley you
would just calmly just be like I know
you didn't want to say I hey man that
you didn't want to make a joke about it
you're just like all right let him do
his thing and do this
you